you have to leave why Lee make me leave
leave make me leave make you leave yeah
make me leave
make sure this is on you have to leave
sir make me leave
say that again
you called me again you're mental
body camera footage captures the
shocking altercation between an Ohio
police officer and a man who authorities
say was suffering from a mental health
crisis you think I'm playing bro huh
ain't nobody fucking mental
the incident happened on September 14th
in Youngstown Ohio according to the
police department the man who you see
here in the red shirt who was later
identified as Keyshawn Sims approached
the lobby of the Department's auxiliary
office demanding to speak to the police
chief okay I'm not exactly sure what
you're talking about
the chief only talks to people if they
make an appointment
you only make you have to make an
appointment with the chief to see him
okay
you can call them
the officer then tells Sims he will call
someone for him however the officer says
that unnamed person is unavailable oh
she's not in her office
and that's when the discussion takes a
turn as the officer tells Sims he is
unable to help him and ask Sims to leave
yeah but everybody you need to talk to
that you want to talk to are uh you have
to make an appointment to see them
well that's the way it's going to be you
can say no all you want
okay
I have someone who actually needs help
can you have
sir
don't be difficult just just
there's no one that will talk to you
no yeah yeah because you're talking
about some kind of manifestation it's
telling is that you know what that tells
me that you're mental
say that again you're mental
the officer then gets up from his desk
and walks to the lobby area where Sims
can be seen waiting for the officer
say it
you have to leave now sir or what you
have to leave now sir call someone right
I'm not calling anything you have to
leave why Lee make me leave leave make
me leave make you leave yeah and then
the confrontation turns physical
you called me hard to say that again
you're mental
I think I'm playing bro huh ain't nobody
fucking mental
you can call somebody so I can talk to
someone the officer tells Sims to get
off of him but shortly after another
physical confrontation happens again
between the two
we can do this all day yes we can yeah
seconds later the officer then pulls out
what appears to be his service weapon
and points it towards Sims and both get
into yet another physical altercation
additional officers are able to come to
the officer's Aid where they tackle Sims
to the ground
out here
who is it yeah
I have no idea
surveillance video shared by the
Youngstown Police Department also
captured the physical confrontation
between Sims and the officer as Sims can
be seen striking the officer repeatedly
Sims can then be seen tackling the
officer and when the officer reached for
his service weapon Sims put the officer
in what appears to be a headlock before
being tackled by another officer to
break up the altercation the officer's
body cam then captures Sims being placed
in handcuffs but not without a final
word from Sims to the officer
again hope so
thank you
um yeah okay let's watch
your first name you that's what it is
Sims was eventually taken away in a
squad car and charged with assault on a
peace officer menacing obstructing
official business aggravated robbery and
intimidation the Youngstown Police
Department says neither of the unnamed
officer or Sim suffered severe injuries
and they are actively considering
additional Crisis Intervention training
to help officers with de-escalation
skills and tactics for encounters such
as this reporting for the long crime
Network I'm Elizabeth Milner